los problemas entre China y Taiwán
continúan acumulándose este miércoles
luego que desde taipei informarán un
cierre del espacio aéreo impuesto por
Beijing al norte de la isla así lo
comunicó el Ministerio de defensa de
Taiwán que aclaró que la decisión se
debe a trabajos aeroespaciales y no
militares
aeroespacial significa actividades
relacionadas con la Aviación y el
espacio a juzgar por la información
pública incluirá misiones relacionadas
con la Aviación y el espacio lo que
significa que podría estar relacionado
con los satélites y las comunicaciones
el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
chino desconoció la afirmación de Taiwán
pero la versión fue ratificada por Corea
del Sur y Japón dos destinos frecuentes
para los vuelos internacionales que se
verán afectados por la medida tanto
taipei como seúl agregaron que la
exclusión era de tres días a partir del
domingo pero se redujo apenas media hora
los civiles de la isla reaccionaron en
medio de una situación tensa entre
Taiwán y la china continental
Estoy preocupado en realidad me preocupa
mucho es una amenaza muy común y
habitual de China continental si dices
que no estás preocupado por esto no creo
que sea cierto todo el mundo está
amenazado todo el tiempo
en realidad en este momento todo se
trata de la guerra entre China y Taiwán
estamos un poco nerviosos pero al mismo
tiempo más o menos Tal vez porque
creemos que Taiwán puede contraatacar o
algo como que china puede sentir
simpatía por nosotros porque tenemos una
gran población aquí en Taiwán
la situación escaló esta semana Luego de
que china realizara ejercicios militares
de tres días alrededor de Taiwán
maniobras que han continuado a pesar de
lo programa